hi this is cynthia thomas and i'm back
to give you the latest on google cloud
edge and security networking launches
that have recently gone ga
stick around
armor what is it
it's google cloud's ddos defense service
and web application firewall that works
to protect your applications and
websites
cloud armor protects your applications
against ddos attacks using the same
technology that's used to protect
google's own services
additionally a host of security
capabilities are available but in this
video we'll focus on the latest and
greatest that are now ga cloud armor
policies have now been extended to help
you mitigate the top 10 oasp web app
vulnerabilities in an easy to configure
fashion
the new pre-configured waf rules include
scanner detection
protocol attack
php injection and session fixation
the available pre-configured rules are
based on owasp mod security core rule
set
the rules allow cloud armor to evaluate
dozens of distinct traffic signatures by
referring to conveniently named rules
instead of requiring you to define each
signature manually
they can be tuned to different
sensitivity levels as well
cloud armor also launched the
capabilities to parse jsons
filter based on asn
and enable verbose logging
incoming requests with json as the
content type often report a high rate of
noise and false positive hits from
pre-configured waf rules
with this release you can now enable
cloud armor to parse the json-formated
content of http requests on a per policy
basis once enabled you can significantly
reduce the noise and false positive
alerts for workloads with requests
containing json
another available rule attribute is
filtering based on an asn
cloud armor lets you allow or deny
incoming requests
serviced from a specific network
operator
defined by their autonomous system
number
finally you can get more logging
information of incoming requests
by default event logs contain the
security rule that was triggered
with verbose logging
cloud armor can generate additional
details in the request logs to include a
snippet of the offending content that
triggered the rule
next let's talk about additions to vpc
service controls your google cloud
service perimeter defense tool
vpc service controls works to prevent
data exfiltration and is a hard
requirement for several financial
services customers
it defines a service perimeter that lets
you protect your organization's
information by controlling access to
resources and managed services data
now vpc service controls has expanded
the services you can include in the
service perimeter it now includes the
cloud file store api
file store is a google managed network
attached storage solution
it works with vms and google kubernetes
engine
and with vpc service controls you can
now control and protect the data
exchange with file store finally let's
talk about vpc service control's
troubleshooter this is a new tool that
enables admins to better understand a
denial caused by vpc service controls
defining your security perimeter can be
tricky while debugging denial errors
you can now easily investigate issues
related to vpc service controls using
the cloud console
use the vpc service control's
troubleshooter via the logs explorer or
from the vpc service controls page
once you enter a unique id for the
logged error you'll be provided with one
of the violation reasons for further
insights into the denial
very handy for confirming and defining
your service perimeters
all right now you're up to date on the
latest networking and edge security
launches
check out the docs link below and let us
know what you think in the comments
join us next time for what's new in
networking